hey guys
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
in today's session we're going to learn
all about
angular bootstrap but before we begin if
you haven't subscribed to our channel
already
make sure to subscribe to it and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
we come up with new videos every day all
right then
let's dive into the topic first
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection
of html css and javascript tools
for creating and building responsive web
applications
and pages it is a free and open source
project
based on github and originally created
by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection
of handy reusable bits of code written
in html
css and javascript it's also a front-end
development framework
that enables developers and beginners to
design
quick and responsive websites now there
are several advantages
to using bootstrap to name a few
bootstrap comes with a responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing
images based on the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use
for your web page these components could
be navigation bars
drop downs progress bars thumbnails
etc it also offers excellent
documentation
and is customizable so bootstrap comes
in extremely handy
to create responsive user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it first up
is by using the bootstrap cdn
or the content delivery network now this
enables users to load css javascript and
images remotely from its servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jquery and other packages and
frameworks
can be installed via the command prompt
in the tutorial that i'm going to be
showing you i've embedded
bootstrap using npm all right so i'm
sure you only understand the concept
better when you look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap
so in this tutorial what i'm going to be
showing is the creation
of a blog post so let me show you what
we're going to be doing
so here i've created a simple blog
for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo
i've also written a few lines about
simply learn and what they offer
i've also mentioned their tag and when
you scroll down
you can see that i've mentioned the
different
courses they're offering and when you
click
on the more info button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for
full stack web development as well
and uh the same for the last one that is
cyber security and finally i've added
a simple video here to just make it more
beautiful so i've added a simple video
and lastly i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the youtube channel
to our youtube channel here all right
so this is what we're going to be
creating
using angular bootstrap so i'm hoping
you're all ready for it
so without further delay let's jump in
so first
let's find the template that we want to
use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap blog
template and i'm just going to click on
the first
link that i get and here
you can choose the template that you
like so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is oh yeah this one
so which is small businesses so you can
go ahead and click on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the
title and then you also have the css
file references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the ui there's code for navigation
bar
and then you have page content code
heading row call to action
and all of that and lastly you have the
footer
so uh what we're going to be doing is
that we'll take all of the code
and then we'll have to create components
for each of it
and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file so that is the best practice
that angular uses so we're going to make
use of components
and you can also see that when you
scroll down you can see that
it has certain dependencies so here it
has the
bootstrap dependency and then you have
jquery so
we'll have to download them so we'll
have to install them
and as mentioned earlier we're going to
be installing them with the help
of npm so for that we'll have to head
back to our vs code
here back in my vs code i've created a
folder called angulardemo and then i've
also created a file called demo
components
and here i'm just going to say
cd demo components
within which i'll say npm install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while and once
you've installed
jquery go ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery
and bootstrap so now we need to add the
references to these javascript files
to do that go to your angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section
so here you can see we have styles and
scripts
so in our scripts array we define the
relative path
to these javascript files so these files
are generally
stored in your node modules so
go ahead and here you can
look for bootstrap here you go
and then in your dist file
and then click on js and then you can
see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here and
make sure to uh make it a path
by providing by providing forward slash
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for
jquery so here there's jquery and then
click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just copy the path
and paste it here
follow the same procedure for this as
well
[Music]
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here in the beginning
they've also included the css file
so we'll have to embed that as well so
here back in bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's bootstrap.min.css i'm just going
to copy the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these to forward
slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right so i think we've
added all the dependencies and the
custom style sheet and everything so
now let me just close all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and
take the code from the source here so
i'm just going to copy
the body tag all right
so i'm going to copy this till the
footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then
place the code for specific parts of the
ui in these components so
let me just see if i've got everything
here okay
so i'll be creating four components
the first one will be for the navigation
bar the second will be
for the introduction and then the third
one
will be uh to display the courses that
we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components i've also created
a components folder here in my app
folder
so i just have to type in the command
ngc first we'll create
the component for the top navigation bar
so i'm just saying
nggc so i'm just gonna say components
[Music]
slash nav bar
[Music]
all right so uh the component has been
created so what i'm going to do is i'll
just
copy this
[Music]
and paste it here
[Music]
all right and the next component i'm
going to be creating
is for the introduction right so i'll
say
ng g c
[Music]
components slash intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action
part so i'll just
copy paste this one in my intro.html
file so let me do that
and then i'm going to have the main
course content
component so for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until um till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here and
finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so
i'll say nggc
components slash footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right so now we'll have to create
the custom html tags for these
components and then
place it in our html file right so
first one that we created was the
navigation bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copy the selector
[Music]
and then here and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags similarly for intro
[Music]
i'm just going to copy the selector
and then for courses so
yeah app hyphen courses
that is well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
[Music]
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact so here let me just
say
ng serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed
so you have the navigation bar you have
the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component
right okay so now that we have the
template ready
we can go ahead and customize it
according to our needs
so now i'm going to be making a few
changes to the code we're going to add
the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here
we're going to display something else
over here all right so
let's go back to our vs code to
customize and
displayed the final output so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here i'm going to
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component let's go to the
html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just
type in simply learn
all right so when you save it and when
you look at the
browser you can see that
simply learn is displayed and the next
thing that i want to do
is i want to add the image right i
simply learn logo
so what i've done here is i've already
added
the logo dot png file in my assets
folder
so i'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this so that's going to be in
our intro files so here
image source is going to be
assets slash
[Music]
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change this part of the
ui so the information that i want to
display
is this i'm going to be displaying
world's number one online boot camp and
other information so what i'm going to
do
is back in my vs code i'm just gonna
delete
this and instead of that i'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online bootcamp and then within the
paragraph tag
i'll display something else so let me
get rid of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
[Music]
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action
message i'm going to display a explore
programs message
so let's go back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here and then
lastly instead of this message here
i want to display the message uh get
certified get ahead without programs
so back in our vs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead
and all of that uh well now what i'm
going to do
is i'm really not happy with the font
size and everything
so i'm just go ahead and add certain
styling you can customize this and
provide your own font size and
all of that so here i'm just going to
mention
style
and then say font size
and i'm going to make it x x large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here
for our courses so
back in our vis code we'll have to
go to the courses component
so here i'm going to just type in the
code for
the different courses so i already have
it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display
let me just copy that and for our first
tag
i'm just gonna say postgraduate program
ending six sigma
and the next information i'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
paste that here let me just break the
line
to beautify the code and then
and here for our reference link
i already have the link here so i'm just
going to paste that
so once you click on the more info
button
it will automatically navigate to this
page
all right so let me see this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in
full stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort
so
let me paste that and also
provide a blind break and then
link i have it here so
i'm just going to paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core
and paste this instead
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
all right so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that the information has
been added
you can see it displays postgraduate
program in lean six sigma full stack
development and cyber security
so once i click on more info it
leads you to that page that shows the
overview
all right so now the next thing on the
agenda was to
uh display a short video and then
the link to our youtube channel so let's
go ahead and add that
in our courses component
uh so what i'm gonna do is i'm just
gonna get the code to add
a video from google and then i'm gonna
provide the source which is going to be
the video that i would want to display
so i've received the code i'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code on google so go
ahead and just paste that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder
which i have provided here so when i
save it
and look at the browser here we go you
can see the video here
all right and once clicked it starts
playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for youtube
and then the link to navigate to the
youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again i've pasted the code
for the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube
dot png in my assets folder and i've
provided the source
and accordingly i've also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned
the text to the center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out our youtube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then i provided the link to our
channel on youtube
so let me just save this and head back
to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube logo and we have the
message displayed
so once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message
here for the footer so here in
footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply on solutions and
all rights reserved
and i save it and look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go so with the help of
bootstrap we have successfully created a
website
which is basically a blog and
we've also added the reference links and
images
and logos to customize it according to
our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you make
use of bootstrap and embed
it into your angular for more responsive
and better user interface
so i hope this tutorial on angular
bootstrap helped you understand the
concept better
i highly suggest you play around and
create your own web pages
so thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here